tamar braxton and her husband Vince are
calling a quiz marriage is not easy
and marriage is definitely not used when
you work together there a lot of things
that is going on in my relationship and
we've been close to this music industry
and whatever I can do to eliminate all
of the stress and problems you know off
of my relationship I would rather do
that protect what's more important got
it
that was Tamar telling ét last month
that she's retiring from her recording
career to protect her marriage now a
source tells us the blind singer has
filed for divorce from her husband of
nearly nine years quote there has been
trouble with the two of them for some
time and it came to a head she's not
broke don't fix it for you so fix it
your hard two minute
a couple share four-year-old son Logan
and have documented the ups and downs of
their relationship on their Wii TV
series Tamar and Vince the show is set
to return for season 5 on November 9th
and don't wanna end up like my parents
to live like how I'm living
[Music]
you